75 يوما من القتال في قطاع غزه ولا تزال
هذه الحرب المستمره متواصله في مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه بالقصف العنيف الذي
تشنه طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه من الشمال من
شمال غزه الى غزه الى دير البلح الى خان
يونس وحتى رفح قصف عنيف ومكثف على مناطق
واسعه من قطاع غزه ولكن العمليات البريه
الاسرائيليه لا تزال تتركز في محورين
رئيسيين المحور الاول هو محور شمال غزه
ومحيط مدينه غزه والمحور الثاني هو مدينه
خان يونس ومحيطه وتحديدا المنطقه الشرقيه
والشماليه الشرقيه من خان يوس اذا ما
بدانا بالمناطق الشماليه من من قطاع غزه
نتحدث عن مناطق متفرقه تدور فيها معارك من
المسافه صفر بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه في بيت لاهيه في بيت
حنون في الشجاعيه وفي مخيم جباليا
بالاضافه الى وسط مدينه غزه من من طرف من
الجهه الغربيه للبلده القديمه في مدينه
غزه محاور القتال لا تتوقف والمعارك
العنيفه بين المسافه الصفر لا تتوقف اذا
ما دخلنا الى مناطق اذا الى المنطقه
الوسطى او منطقه وسط مدينه غزه فنتحدث عن
نقاط اساسيه للقتال نتحدث عن قتال عنيف في
الشجاعيه مع توغل الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه من المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه
والمنطقه الجنوبيه الغ يه الى الشجاعيه
يقابلها قتال عنيف من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه واستهداف لاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
تقدم نحوها من اكثر من جانب صاحه السرايه
كان هناك استهداف لجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وقتل عدد منهم وايضا كان هناك
استهداف لجنود تمركزوا في حي الدرج في
المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من مدينه غزه
وقتل عدد منهم وفق اعلانات كتائب القسام
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه هذا الامر تزامن مع
قصف عنيف لطيران الاسرائيلي على مناطق
متفرقه من الصبره الى تل الهواء بطبيعه
الحال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يضغط بشكل كبير
بتشكيل احزمه ناريه وقصف عنيف على مناطق
متفر اليوم احد ابرز مشاهد القصف كانت
اليوم في هذه المنطقه المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه من منطقه الشجاعيه هذه منطقه
الشجاعيه بطبيعه الحال هذه ناحى العوز
وهذا معبر المنطار المغلق وهذه الشجاعيه
الجهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه من الشجاعيه شهدت
اليوم قصفا باحزمه ناريه كلف او دمر حوالي
56 مبنى في هذه المنطقه قصف عنيف من
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
والمتوج في هذه النقطه اذا بتحد تحدثنا عن
التوغل فنحن نتحدث عن هذا التوغل الذي
يمتد وفق الاشاره هنا الى حوالي كيلو ونص
توغلت الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وقصفت
بشكل كبير هذه المنطقه من المنطقه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه من حي الشجاعيه ودمرت
حيا ب كاملا يزيد على 50 مبنى اذا ما
انتقلنا الى المعارك في الجهه الجنوبيه
فنحن نتحدث عن منطقه خانيونس التي تدور
فيها معارك عنيفه وتحديدا في المنطقه
الشرقيه والشماليه الشرقيه من خانيونس مع
توغل الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه من
اكثر من محور باتجاه خان يونس وتحديدا
المنطقه الشرقيه من عبسان باتجاه بنسه
هيلا ومنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من الخط
الفاصل او السياج الفاصل باتجاه الزنه
وباتجاه خانيونس يرود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الضغط باكبر قدر ممكن على وسط مدينه
خانيونس لانه يقول بانها مركز عمليات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ومركز عمليات كتائب
القسام وفيها يتواجد يحيى السنوار وقياده
كتائب القسام ولكن في المقابل تقول كتائب
القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه انها تتصدى
بشكل واضح محدد للاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وتوقع خسائر واضحه
وفادحة الجنوبيه خان يونس
ومحيطها